alors ivana trump questions importantes
si demain matin
donald trump revenez vers vous et vous
proposer de reprendre la vie de famille
avec vos enfants
il y en oublie tout on se remet ensemble
tous et on reprend une vie normale tu me
pardonnes excuse moi est ce que vous
seriez d'accord est ce que vous lui
diriez oui ou non au sénat à ce stade je
dirais non et je suis pas convaincu
d'abord parce que je suis amoureuse d'un
autre homme
et puis y est tellement de mal qui a été
fait bon bien sûr à surmonter et
maintenant les enfants ont réussi à
atteindre un stade de paix paisible et
moi je veux continuer avec madoff et
puis donald a des intérêts qu'ils sont
différents à manger des intérêts
différence passe beaucoup de temps en
europe
je jouis de ma vie je fais des choses
différentes et lui continue à travailler
travailler travailler ces milliards et
c'est pas fait pour moi ce n'est plus et
paul n'auront aucun espoir on allume à